I want your viewers to ask themselves do
I feel the richest I've ever been
because I tell you who's the richest
they' ever been me and probably you and
probably you and Donald Trump and Elon
Musk and in my opinion what I see I'm
from a poor background but I think but I
think you're a great example of somebody
who's made something of himself come
from a you know a poor workingclass
Background by your own admission and you
turned yourself into the best Trader in
the world you're a great example and yet
what you seem to be wanting to do is is
almost Retreat I don't want I don't want
to tax working people more okay I worked
to drag my family out of poverty right
and I paid 50 60% a year tax at the same
time juk of Westminster inherits 10
billion pounds more than 3,000 times
what I made pays nothing do you think
that's fair no do you think that's fair
no but again let's change it let tax
working people less your viewers less
and let's text the billionaires more